-From the first film, we know
that you are sort of the cooler
of the two dads.
-Yeah.
-You and Will --
I think it comes across
in the clip, as well.
What about -- You have children.
You had a premiere for the film.
Do they think it´s cool
that their dad is Mark Wahlberg?
Did they come to the premiere?
-They did not come
to the premiere.
-Really?
-They basically refused
to come to the premiere.
-Why -- Why did they refuse?
-They were like, "Dad,
we´ll see it
whenever we see it."
I´m like, "Come on, everybody
is going to be there.
Will´s going to be there.
John Cena is going to be there."
They had no interest.
And, of course, Will shows up
with his wife and the kids
and they´re all in suits and
dressed up and --
But, you know,
they just didn´t want to go.
The boys were watching football.
My daughter is on the phone,
doing her thing.
-Do they just -- Do you think
it´s that they aged out
of their dad being cool?
Do you think your heyday
of being a cool dad is over?
-It´s been over.
-Okay.
-You know, so now I´m like,
I don´t make a point
to embarrass them,
but I´m not going to try to hide
my affection for them either.
So, they´re like, "Dad, drop us
off in the alley at the school."
And I´m like "No.
I´m going to walk you in.
I´m getting a kiss
in front of all your friends.
And that´s it."
But, if they need something,
if they want to meet Drake,
or they want somebody that,
you know, they know Dad knows
or can hookup...
-Yeah.
-...then they´ll say, "Oh, yeah
Dad, we think you´re cool
for five minutes."
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
So they´re not smart enough,
if they want to meet Drake,
to, like, be nice for a week
leading up to the ask?
They just --
-For a week? No.
They´ll be nice
for five minutes.
If they don´t get
what they want, when they want,
they´re just right back
to not talking to me
or just, you know, being,
you know, kids.
But, you know, they´re kids,
so I understand.
-I´m not that --
My son is a year and a half,
and he´s just super.
I think he thinks I´m the
coolest dude he´s ever met
´cause he´s only met
like six dudes.
[ Laughter ]
-Enjoy it while it lasts.
-Yeah, I´m going to.
-And more importantly,
be grateful
that it´s not a girl.
And, now, mind you,
the best relationship
that I have with my daughter --
Daddy/daughter relationship
is great,
but when they become teenagers,
something happens.
You have no idea
what to do about it,
how to handle it.
The hormones, the emotions.
It´s absolute torture, so --
I mean, watch out.
-That´s really sweet.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it´s sweet
until it happens to you.
And like I said, we´re cool.
But you know what?
The whole thing with the boys
and all of this stuff,
I´m just not ready for it.
-Yeah, I gotcha.
So, I want to ask about this
because Will was here yesterday
and I didn´t have a chance
to ask him about it.
But your assistant --
Did your assistant get a part
in the film in the end?
-He got a part in the end,
but he got cut.
-Oh, he got cut.
-Yeah, and he only auditioned
for like one line.
One word, really.
-Okay.
He´s yelling one word
in the audience
of the -- the improv club.
But we made him audition
to Tim Hutton´s
most emotional scenes
in "Ordinary People."
-[ Laughs ] So wait --
-And he spent weeks and weeks
and weeks studying these scenes,
learning the lines.
Like, he emoted
in front of me and Will
and Chris Henchy for like --
-So you made him audition
in front --
He didn´t have to audition.
He auditioned for you
and Will and Chris Henchy.
-We are the producers
of the film.
We basically said, "Yes.
You have to do this."
And you know what?
He did a good job.
But then they -- he didn´t --
he did a good job
in the audition,
but maybe didn´t do a good job
in the actual scene.
-Yeah, so you had to --
-So the scene got cut.
What can I do?
But I told Tim Hutton.
Tim Hutton and I worked
on a movie after that,
and I told him, and Tim really
wanted to see the footage.
-Oh, really?
Did you show --
-I didn´t get it in time.
And I don´t think
he would have --
I think at first he thought
we were paying homage,
but then I think I realized
that he might not
have liked it after he saw it.
-Wasn´t quite
up to Tim´s standards.
-Right, exactly.
-Won an Oscar for that part.
-He did win an Oscar
for that part.
I forgot that.
Now, I also heard that --
so Will -- John Lithgow
plays Will´s father.
-Uh-huh.
-And they have a fight scene.
And you encourage them
not just to go for it
when you were shooting it,
but to like actually physically
go for it in rehearsal.
-John is a method guy.
Will is -- You know how Will --
-Yeah.
-He´s a such sweet guy, right?
So he doesn´t want
to say anything to John.
So, like, you know, when they
had to do the first
big, long, awkward kiss, right,
I´m like, "Oh,
that was really good.
You guys got to do that again."
And then I keep telling John,
"Do it more often."
Then John is doing it
at rehearsals,
he´s doing it when
they´re just blocking the scene.
And Will
would never say anything,
but I could tell
he was getting annoyed.
So I would start, you know --
It was giving me great pleasure.
[ Laughter ]
And then when they started
doing the fight scene,
you know, John was just, like,
putting him in a headlock.
And you could tell Will --
´cause, like, we did 15 takes
of the first scene
where I had to give him
a heart pump
and try to revive him.
And he didn´t say anything
until, like, I almost caved
his chest in.
He was like, "Maybe now
that you got the hard one in,
you do one of those soft ones.
You probably have
a soft one in you."
So I´m like, "Okay."
So, and then John
was just torturing him.
It was a lot of fun.